rates of change as a two-unit idea we
have encountered already it's very
simple think about this right when we
say something like this right we write
dy DX that we use that as our notation
for differentiating versus this notation
for integrating now you will recall that
these notations each come from somewhere
when they each come from somewhere this
elongated s right it's actually kind of
borrowed from Sigma notation right look
I'm adding up a whole bunch of things
and that's why it's Esper some yeah I'm
adding things up and it's just that
while the Super's already been used for
that and so we use this notation because
it's got the same kind of call back and
has the same sort of like you remember
Sigma notation
it's got you've seen this in induction
recently it's got that value at the
bottom which is like where you start now
value the top which is where you end and
that's where these are lower and upper
bounds come from yeah yeah
this notation for the derivatives would
be development earlier also has a
similar kind of story
good morning it's written as a ratio
between two things like something over
something issue between what that one
when we first met derivatives what's the
top coming from last one couples this is
just done this is just gradient it isn't
it it's rise and we read this as we're
in that date as it's kind of standing
for Delta which we mean is like change
yeah which we see in kind of a you know
in a chemical reaction in photos of
unique chemistry or job don't want right
we said you start with some stuff some
kind of change happens usually the
changes like people or whatever it is
and then you get something out the other
pair
okay so Delta the Greek letter Delta
course went into a little D that's what
that refers to
okay change in why I want to compare
that to the change in X now when we look
at rates of change rates of change we
can hear the word rate basically what
you
something is changing over time right so
instead of dy 20x it's gonna be
something over DT right so I want to
investigate how some particular quantity
is changing with respect to time now
what we add is extension one students is
what Accord related rates the idea be
and um here's an example you've got
different kinds of things within the
situation that are all changing with
respect to time and these things are
connected to each other right so it's
like if you have a look at this question
and it will start to unpack the sin is
being fought on different table
pile at the rape off and then they give
you another okay so stop for a moment
and just try to get a picture in your
head I hope you haven't looked at the
next week sentence of a spoiler for
yourself there is a pile of sand and
it's growing and growing
hey girl yeah if you're just like if
you're not mucking around with it you
don't have like a bucket or something
like that what is the shape of this pile
of sand as you're pouring right yeah and
it's going to be conical isn't because
it starts with this little spot and it
grows up and up and up but obviously
because it's unstable it can't just grow
like a tower okay so it's sort of just
periods out like this okay
so draw with me let's draw a diagram and
for all weights have changed questions
but particularly related raise questions
your diagram you will live or die with
the basis of your diagram okay so don't
make this too small we're gonna have to
do some labeling on it and so on you
suggested to me that there's going to be
this conical shape so here's my pile of
sail yep and importantly what I'm right
here represents the Pylos in an instant
in time so this pile is in at some point
in time it didn't exist it was a tiny
little dot and then further time it's
going to get bigger right so this
represents like I snapped a photo okay
so I'm trying to represent change but I
have to do it this static medium so this
is my plan
particular boat it's being ported to the
top of a pile so he comes to send up
here and so this code is getting larger
and larger at the rate of 3 liters cube
per minute okay let's just write that
down for a second
3 meters cubed now you remember I said
to you in rates of change landed instead
of do you want yet you read do something
on DT you're gonna get two T's over and
over again and the way you can know is
when you look at this if I like this is
the same form that I've got here which
opposed is right I would write this as 3
meters cubed over one minute
really that's this is when I say three
meters per minute maybe 3 minutes or 3
meters cubed 3 meters cubed per
individual business right so there's
really a comparison of two units here
which is what makes it a rate and you
can see here it tells you what it is
right this is our DT because minutes are
a unit of time they could just as easily
be hours or days or seconds if we wanted
to so you can see this is her DT or the
bottom meters cubed what's that a
measure off until it's a unit of volume
visitor okay so up at the top here I'm
going to call this and by convention we
usually use a capital v we aren't we
tend to reserve the lowercase V for
velocity which we'll talk about later at
the motion so this is my rate of change
of the volume of a pile of sand and it's
important because this is related rates
and we're gonna have lots of different
derivatives flying around you remember I
said to you rather beginning when people
introduce this notation and they also
introduce this notation right now that
we're gonna integrate slid right this -
notation becomes completely insufficient
because it's kind of like what's being
differentiated with respect to what just
state it just a you're not really like
people say oh it's faster not really
okay so I've got a change of the volume
with detector time the pile always
remains in the shape of a cone has
spoilers with semi vertical angle 45
degrees now that's a bit of specific
language there so the semi vertical
angle semi better
it's half of some particular acre where
is this able it's gonna be up there at
the top yeah so I'm going to actually
put in a vertical line here sets
perpendicular to the base like so and
the 45 degrees that they're thinking of
you can I mean in this case you actually
could draw it on either side because 45
degrees is gonna equal what they really
need is the inside okay how do you say
that well you're really describing the
shape there's two reasons you can do
they're describing the shape of the
curve not the shape of the knot code so
they are the other angle I suppose you'd
say the angle of depression is outside
the cone so you're actually describing
the cone anything
sorry you mean down here well that would
come from the signal right now the
reason I knew this egg was up here and
not down there is cuz the semi vertical
angles are measuring from the vertical
okay so as opposed to horizontal I guess
but I've never seen something you
referred to as those semi okay so there
you go there's my picture and then he
asked us a couple of questions now
before we look at these questions what
should you just know like I'm sorry
before we solve these questions I want
you to know that these are these related
rates right now I'm trying to think
about the rate of the height changing so
I'm after not DV DT but da Chen DT and
the base area so I guess by convention
we call that da or did